tonight german chancellor olaf schultz
says that russia will face severe
economic and political consequences if
it invades ukraine now that warning came
as envoys from russia ukraine germany
and france convened today here in berlin
more attempts at diplomacy to avert a
war while more than a hundred thousand
russian troops remain positioned along
the border with ukraine
the numbers continue to grow
more troops more military hardware
and more big booms in video offered to
the media by the russian defense
ministry
[Applause]
and even if these big booms are only for
drills they are meant to be loud just as
russia's foreign ministry is being loud
and responding to overtures from the
west to turn the volume down
idealized approaches ultimatums threats
and lecturing
it's a path to nowhere
unfortunately many of our western
colleagues are now obsessed with this
form of public activity
i can't call it diplomacy
these ukrainian troops in the donbass
region were deployed at first to keep
russia-backed separatists at bay
now they're watching and waiting for
what they think will be an assault by
russian troops on the other side of the
border
we're ready and very motivated we know
who we're defending the ukrainian people
are behind us our home
we're ready to stand our ground until
the end
the donbass region though may not be the
main prize for russia as dw heard from a
chair of the european council on foreign
relations
i mean it's good that sort of berlin and
paris is now sort of accelerating
efforts on donbass on the means process
but we should understand that the
russian game at the moment is much
bigger uh donbass is a sideshow i have
to say
the russian game if you listen to mr
putin and see the documents that they've
put on the table is about ukraine as a
whole and it's about sort of changing
the entire european security order
as the u.s moves troops into romania to
bolster nato's border along the black
sea
carl biltz says it is in fact the u.s
and nato that russia most wants to deal
with
dw's chief international editor richard
walker spoke to latvia's prime minister
about how his country is dealing with
the russian buildup
prime minister carriage how dangerous is
the situation at the moment how close
are we to a possible war
well it's not clear
if there will or won't be a war but one
thing is clear president putin
is fighting against ukraine's
independence against their democracy
that's the threat that he feels
he talks about the encroachment of nato
but what he's really fighting is the
independence
of ukraine and this is what we in the
west what we in the european union and
what we as nato member states
have an obligation to support is
ukrainian independence that is what is
at stake but you do see the troops that
are amassed around ukraine as a real
threat a potential threat that could
lead to conflict of course it's a very
real threat we've seen the exercises
before last spring
much higher troop concentrations uh
there's a refusal to allow uh
observation of the exercises in belarus
which are also unannounced so there are
troops not only along the ukrainian
russian border but there are russian
troops now in belarus on the northern
border of ukraine as well now of course
latvia has a border with belarus itself
do you feel that there is a direct risk
to your country
my country is a member of nato as are
all three uh baltic countries so of
course we have uh as we speak today ten
nato member state uh militaries in
latvia there's the the german uh led uh
contingent of nato in lithuania the
british that contingent in estonia so we
don't feel a direct
military threat but certainly this is
very destabilizing for the entire region
and it changes the military posture
and we as nato member states need to
react i think it's very
important to strengthen nato's presence
all along the eastern flank that is
from the baltic down to the black sea
but especially of course also in the
baltic countries and this is where
germany is playing now an important role
germany has made the decision to
strengthen its presence in lithuania
which is very welcome news indeed now in
the discussion of trying to deter
vladimir putin from taking military
action there's a lot of focus on
sanctions possible sanctions and
nordstrom 2 is at the heart of that
debate wolf schultz the german
chancellor has refused to explicitly say
that he would put sanctions on
nordstream 2. what's your message to him
on that
the message is very simple everything
has to be on the table for it to be a
credible deterrent
putin has to understand that the
sanctions could bite in many different
ways so as long as nothing is taken off
of the table this is the way that we
have to move forward now you're a
long-standing critic of nordstream 2.
when you look at the current situation
do you feel that nordstrom 2 contributed
to this crisis
well we've been critics of north stream
one so all along and we have said from
the very beginning that such an undersea
a gas pipeline to germany will or could
at some point be used by russia as a
geopolitical
lever and we see that this is what the
kremlin is doing right now using gas
supplies to europe as a pressure with
reduced flows and thereby increasing
energy prices in europe
we thought it was a bad idea then and we
think it's a bad idea now for europe to
become too over dependent on energy
supplies from any one country especially
if that country is
russia and we know that gas promise is
state-controlled export monopoly it is
being used now as an economic tool
against uh the european union prime
minister current many thanks for your
time thank you
for more now i'm joined by sophia besh
she's an expert on european defense
policy at the center for
european reform it's good to see you
again let's let's talk about the
influence that um european allies such
as france and germany
have right now i mean do they have much
influence on what vladimir putin is
going to do
well that's a good question i mean
france and germany are obviously
influential powers in europe and they
are important voices in this crisis not
least because they would suffer under
economic sanctions should the conflict
get to that stage
and you know they have often cast
themselves as sort of mediating powers
in relations with russia germany has
historically often pursued the role of a
diplomatic mediator macron has
throughout his presidency attempted to
forge new negotiation paths with putin
and now they are trying to exert their
influence for instance as you said
through the normandy forum the benefits
of that forum is that we have ukraine
and russia both at the table
the hope is that we can use it to come
to a diplomatic solution revive the
so-called minsk accords that were struck
after
russia last invaded ukraine but they are
notoriously ambiguous they are
interpreted differently by all the
parties and they have never been fully
implemented in the end i think these
attacks can only succeed france and
germany can only succeed if russia
engages as a good faith participant
which is less than clear at this time
yeah that's a that's a very questionable
position at the moment we know the
biggest counterpart to putin is of
course u.s president joe biden
how much influence can france and
germany have on the white house at this
moment
well
the us and the europeans have been
really closely coordinated in this
crisis i would say um increasingly so no
one wants a war and as a western
alliance we have opted for this sort of
two-pronged strategy of deterrence on
the one hand and dialogue on the other
hand early on you know u.s and russia
have engaged in bilateral talks over
arms control issues and confidence
building measures and france and germany
have in recent days really increased the
intensity of their own diplomatic
efforts
you know we've had macron in moscow and
kiev we have schultz's conversations uh
with the leaders of the baltic states
today with poland's president and then
his planned trip to moscow i think those
conversations are important because
france and germany are really strongest
when they have the credibility and the
legitimacy of representing some sort of
broader european interest
and for that it's incredibly important
that they closely engage with and listen
to the interests and concerns of other
european states before they speak to
moscow or for that matter to to
washington yeah you know earlier this
week the french president emmanuel
macron he was in moscow to meet with
vladimir putin and it's important to
note that macron is
facing re-election in just two months
time he's been criticized for maybe
campaigning if you will
at the kremlin the german chancellor he
goes to the kremlin next week
should should he do anything differently
from what we saw macron do this week
charles is in a really difficult
position going to moscow because it's so
difficult to see what a diplomatic
off-ramp could look like at this point
and mccall faced the same issue you know
to your point whether he's campaigning
in the kremlin i think we've heard
throughout my presidency he has taken an
interest in relations with russia in
trying to re-engage the kremlin but it's
less and less clear what a compromise
could look like between western values
and russian interests at this point you
know russia seems to want to reinstate a
policy of spheres of influence in
europe's east denying a country like
ukraine the freedom to choose its own
alliances influence its broader politics
and foreign policy and europe and the us
are sort of sworn to protect the
decision-making autonomy and territorial
integrity of ukraine and any compromise
on the status of ukraine would
essentially undermine this this stance
of the west plus you know there is the
question of what message russia would
take away if it succeeded to essentially
blackmail us into a concession macron
did not get you know a silver bullet
deal when he went to moscow he did get
some tentative concessions on exercises
in batteries but we cannot be sure if
they're trustworthy and we heard the
nato section say today that the russian
militable that keeps intensifying the
crisis keeps
getting diceier and it seems
increasingly schultz's visit is becoming
a visit at the 11th hour you know that
the pressure is certainly on
sofia bash from the center for european
reform sophie as always we appreciate
your time and your insights thank you
thank you so much